a bad news for Herschel Walker we're
still waiting on you Herschel Walker
polling I think although we'll take a
look in a moment as to whether we have
new polling uh Herschel Walker it turns
out urged his girlfriend to have a
second abortion she says to the New York
Times this is uh reported by CNBC so
remember the story here
was that early last week this Scandal
broke wherein Georgia Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker who claims to
be against abortion in all cases uh
abortion is murder no exceptions for
incest rape life of the mother none of
it none of it turns out that he was
accused credibly with receipts of urging
and then paying for an ex-girlfriend of
his to get an abortion because it would
have been inconvenient remember
abortions murder
rape incest no inconvenience was a
legitimate reason for him to urge and
then pay for a woman to get an abortion
the new report is he actually urged her
to get a second abortion and she didn't
uh CNBC writes a woman who accused
Herschel Walker of paying for her
abortion in 2009 revealed he urged her
to end a second pregnancy
per the New York Times the woman said
their relationship ended after she
refused to have the second procedure
according to the report the trump-backed
Georgia Republican running to unseat
Rafael Warnock has denied paying for an
abortion that denial is not particularly
credible at this point in time Walker
has denied knowing who the woman is
despite reporting from both the times
and the daily beasts that she's the
mother of a son she had with Walker so I
believe there's four
I I don't have it in front of me but I
believe that there's four women at least
with whom he's had children
you would think that he would say well
if it's one of those four women I must
know who it is it's all crazy and the
question now is will this end the
candidacy we still don't have any new
polling I I hope by tomorrow or later
today there will be new polling taken
after the Scandal started
he should be done
whether he will be is unclear because
many of these Georgia Republicans are
rationalizing the whole thing and saying
well he would still ban abortion he fine
he went and paid for one but he would
still vote to ban it
um let's see what the new polling shows
Raphael Warnock should be winning by 40.
they tentatively had a debate scheduled
for this Friday uh Walker has reportedly
still not confirmed that he will be
there and so we will follow that closely
and if indeed they do have that debate
you can be sure that I will be streaming
that live
our sponsor magic spoon is the breakfast
cereal that tastes amazing but without
the sugar carbs and the crazy
ingredients magic spoon has taken your
favorite childhood cereals and
brilliantly transformed them into
something you can feel good about eating
because each serving has zero grams of
sugar under five net carbs and is packed
with 13 grams of protein so it'll work
for keto and low carb but it's really
perfect for anyone who wants the
occasional sweet crunchy treat without
the sugar their portfolio of eight plus
unique delicious flavors allow you to
never get bored my favorite is maple
waffle but they've got the classics like
cocoa fruity frosted also cinnamon roll
blueberry muffin our entire team has
been eating magic spoon for years we
love it but if you don't they send you
all your money back it's really easy
magic spoon has been supporting the
David Pacman show for a long time they
all always give my audience five dollars
off when you go to magicspoon.com Pacman
and use the code Pacman the link is down
below